this is
game three between magnus cross and
david anton if magnus wins it he will
also be ready for semi-finals and the
bar is over to his side it is over to
his side i should mention great drawing
chances for david anton but magnus is
surely the only one who can win this
game if we do a quick count white has
one extra pawn and everything's defended
for now magnus is definitely in control
winning this is going to be hard though
black does have a blockade white's extra
pawn is the one on the c5 square and if
you look on the c file black has a nice
rook there blockading black is also an
active rook behind which is going to
check you're going to attack pawns it's
going to create a bit of nuisance so
how would you estimate here black's
drawing chances simon
i'm against the normal human being
pretty good against magnus zero
so i hope basically i mean you know
magnus of pawn up in an ending uh well
i've seen him we've seen him do it so
many times on the tour
he's just phenomenal at just getting
anything out of position i mean you know
the at least black has that one active
rook and a blockade so it's not simple i
don't know how it's supposed to be done
but um if there is a way magnus will
will find it
yeah i thought magnus probably has good
quite
quite good chances of uh winning this i
mean
okay he has to find a safe place for his
king and just keep an eye on the c6 rook
but
you know i think simon's right we only
think he's got good winning chances
because it's magnus
if i if i was black here against anyone
else in the world i would think yeah
i'll draw this one no problem
uh but
i mean you didn't i wouldn't have no
confidence you do have the blockade and
you've got an active rook so it's like
and he's coming forwards with the king
but uh
yeah
i wasn't sure this one was possible
though because black's rook can now
slide behind giving a check and then
when the right white rook blocks the
black rook can kind of go to attack
white's sequence rookie seven i think is
nice okay we have to show this simon um
yeah you spotted a tactic there and uh
magnus definitely spotted this one white
king bravely wandering into the center
of the board king of the hill as we call
it and now the black rook if it slides
behind with a check there's only one
legal move for white here but it is
sufficient and this has happened on the
board white's rook blocks and now if the
black rook moves away i thought this
might force a draw because you are
attacking this pawn but now a deflection
tech
tactic check and once the black king
moves away you win this black rook
suddenly your king breaks free and you
win this pawn will decide the game but
uh in the end we did see a trade instead
black's rook had to capture the white
rook and now this pawn is the one under
fire what is magnus gonna do here is he
gonna step his king back to the center
of the board maybe and uh allow his pawn
to drop but at least now he can push
this guy forward with a check that looks
very good yeah i was also thinking maybe
you could put the rook on that square
and move the king towards black's pawns
but i like your idea david just trying
to use that past pawn um but actually
this one i think yours is better simon i
just realized if my move moving the king
forward suddenly the black rook can come
up one square and look at this the white
king is stuck the white rook is stuck no
legal moves the white pawn is pinned oh
wow you could be worse of a sudden
suddenly you have to move back with the
king and you lose your pawn so i think
my suggestion there would have been a
big mistake i like your and better i
think i think there should be winning
because when the black king goes
one way you uh let's see if the black
king goes
to the right okay okay
nice trick another little trick yeah
that's that's very nice magnus this is
dirty pushing the pawn forward if the
pawn is captured then suddenly a
discovered attack white's pawn stepping
forward with a check hitting the black
king and suddenly the black rook would
drop afterwards unprotected
yeah what a move this is a maybe the
killer blow pushing this pawn forward uh
this pawn is poisoned as we just showed
and if you can't take it
sad decision you just have to move back
maybe with your rook yeah
and we were talking about uh the opening
was the birds opening but in actual fact
you know this is the the chesapeal
chessboard competition and uh it follows
that course that kind of opening that um
he had uh against a vidit
so this this uh chess ball course that
myself and richard palastra actually
made
um the the british grand prix so he's
played that a couple of times in this
tournament which is nice to see it's
always nice when you you know you you
sort of make a course and the world
champion plays it sort of uh statue of
approval it is yeah certainly so maybe
now is the time to move forward with the
king simon also mentioned it's possible
to check with the white rook and try to
bring the king this way potentially um a
couple of very tempting moves either
king ford or rook checking on this
square it looks like magnus is finding
ways to win
i think you're right yevanka i shouldn't
have doubted this position very very
good for white now
all right and if magnus wins he will be
ready for the semifinals to meet either
ding or mamadira of game four has now
started and it is a must-win situation
for shakira and mamadiarov any other
result means that ding is the player to
face magnus tomorrow and the bar is over
to pregnant on that side in game three
against uh wei yi which is a must-win
situation for hawaii
so it looks good for prague nanda to
meet geary in semi-finals tomorrow yeah
i took a look at that game weiyi taking
some massive risks to try and win
understandably but pragmata has those
famous drunk pawns the triple pawns
so weird position yeah so great fighting
chess from those two i would love to see
another long battle those two have had
long long games yeah there's two
warriors
but a sign of young players
yeah fighting it out and that's one
thing i think um i mean anish explained
why giri offered the draw it's
understandable he wants to get a draw uh
arientari but
yeah sometimes you just have to battle
things out you just have to forget the
prospect of a loss it's painful but you
need to just fight every chance
um yeah it might count eventually so
look at the white king i was going to
say i love what magnus has done
and now
there's some
i guess there's some some ideas of
pushing the c pawn but you have to
obviously time it
you can't do it just yet yeah basically
white's rook can move now got a couple
of squares you can choose from
potentially um the white king could
slide across one square
maybe you can come into e7 i i don't
know if tax i wasn't sure about that
because if rook takes pawn yeah then i
was going to take a pawn i think he's
played it okay this rook now is
marauding it's going for a couple of
pawns if black tries to distract the
white king taking this guy hoping for
king takes rook and suddenly black is
winning black has this extra pawn uh but
the problem is uh as simon mentioned is
after this pawn is captured i'm not sure
which one you want to take here simon
it's happened
a7 okay both look good to me but he's
taking this board and then you thread
and check mate threatening checkmate
also threatening this black rook and the
problem is where do you put this black
rook if you bring it up to the top of
the board which he has done now you go
the whole way across i love your arm
movement there i know
i'd love to see you doing this in the
game just rather than move the pieces
just like swing the arm i'm swinging
that was the arm movement just swing the
right swing around swing it there swing
it back swing it across everywhere yeah
check mate threatened white's rookie
steps one square up that's game over i
think we're in the closing stages now
white is one porn up but it's not just
about that it's what simon mentioned
earlier active king active rook black's
pieces are terribly placed
magnus can win this game in many ways
just slide his rook across one square go
after black's remaining pawn
slide the rook back one square the one
thing you don't want to do
maybe it's still okay is to move the
white king across defend your rook
because then black can come and give
some checks definitely don't want to go
for that one so move the white rook
swing it over somewhere yeah do the arm
movement swing
swing it to no he doesn't
but he kind of swung it just a little
bit it was more reverse just kind of
nudged it backwards yeah no
i i really wanted to wreck the swing
across because then you can stop those
type of moves nasty trap here from david
anton if you get greedy and grab the
black pawn the black rook was about to
come down and give a check to the white
king so white's king runs to safety
first i don't know why magnus did this i
mean just
i think he knows that this is he's going
to win the second pawn and it's quite an
easy sort of winning position so it's
just fair enough there's probably a
couple of ways to i like your swinging
moves maybe he just did it because you
know he wanted to give some false hope
to david anton
cruel yeah cruel sadistic play so
possibly yeah you think it's a draw no
it's not right yeah and this one is
winning two extra pawns now there are
some scenarios actually where the white
eng pawns together two extra pawns they
don't win the game um if you if the
black king is well played so if the
white king is badly placed the black
brook can give some checks resigned
there we go two points are enough
black gives up and that means magnus
carlsen is ready for the semi-finals